do you think that crowdfunding is
hurting or even ruining social media
wow that's a really really hard question
I explained it to me a little bit
morning within what do you mean well it
seems like
it's great to follow people it's great
to be supportive of what they're doing
but when you feel that they've friended
you or they followed you and they're
singing your praises and then a week
later they let you know about their
crowdfunding campaign it almost feels as
if social media has now become more
about marketing instead of being social
okay um yes the answer is yes and let me
give you an example and I think this is
a huge mistake from people making
projects you know you come push it you I
mean it's stupid to ask people for money
we have never done that in three years
actually our friends you know it's like
first thing you do when you make a
crowdfunding campaign is just harass
your friends like a brought me give me
money share this what I mean even with
my friends I tell them it's like you why
let me discover it let me I mean I'm not
gonna like it because it's you I'm gonna
like it because I like it so let me
discover it let me let me just you know
give me a pretend to watch it but don't
ask me to vote you or to give you money
because you are you and that's a huge
mistake that I can kill project so you
know we never push it that way we just
food to play online and it was funny
because our friends you know it took
like two years for them to give us money
you know two years when we have been a
success in Spain we've been in every
medium and everything they decided to
put money and you know it was amazing
because at that point I felt that that
the project was a success you know when
even my friends that you were tired
listen listen me talk about the project
they decided to get in so I think it's
important not to push it and you know
have a different idea what social is and
I'm work funny knees like make friends
and that's okay and they were going to
help you probably to you know to talk
about the project but if you're asking
them for money do it in a different
platform Lord to it or don't do it at
all I mean let the other people talk
about you
that's much more powerful somebody talks
you